hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play train
okay the same mechanic worked and we're
dropped off right outside this room full
of these people who I totally trust
because as in every horror game I've
ever played when the lights go on and
suddenly the room becomes populated
that's when things are gonna become all
happy he'll pee and gonna be lovely
times in the future so let's see what's
wrong with you what's good hi
are you doing what's wrong with you
what's wrong with you what's wrong with
me
I'm just going up to random people like
what's wrong with you hey why are you
weird I'm normal shut up I'm that crazy
guy in the subway what are you doing you
hacking up over here you're about to die
or turn into a monster but that kids
singing geez kid jeez get some music
lessons you're terrible sorry to insult
your son right here but he can't sing
where the damn you find them okay
things seemed perfectly normal so far am
i missing something here because
something does not seem right oh no no
no no no no whoo no no no no no
that oh that's a car to smoke
nope uh-uh holy hell what the hell oh my
god
oh that is so weird oh you're so weird
you're making weird noises oh my god oh
my god oh my god oh my god oh we got
weird okay okay go away go away go away
go away
this vanette nightmare fantasy don't
look at them they don't exist oh you
want oh this is why I close my eyes okay
you don't exist you don't exist bad god
stop it
I don't blink blink don't look at him ah
I thought something happened
Oh a can barely see down the bottom of
my eyes I'm just gonna hang on
blink occasionally so that oh these guys
are headless over here I wonder where
their heads are you three please give me
bread move please thank you with the
helmet let's go what what do i do what
do i do what do i do what do i do they
won't get out of my why
oh wait please go oh my god oh my god
you're so weird
oh ho you're so weird they're just added
integer digit oh my god this is this
like the freakiest thing I've ever seen
in a game oh my god this is so well done
and so horrified i blaze into all of my
fears I hated
kids what happened to the I something
happens LBJ's what's on the TV it's
different now red hey oh you're so weird
you're so weird you're so weird it's so
weird it's a weird can I get out can I
get out I don't you stop laughing at me
okay I don't know what happened well
where's the TV go oh there it is huh oh
no they got me I looked at them too long
haha oh my god oh my god oh hi what you
doing there okay don't look at him this
kind of blink quickly to see where
you're going and then don't look at him
what do I do I'm so confused
I can't look long enough to see anything
other the heads will come rushing by
there's got to be a way to get past
these guys got to be away what is that
Oh found something what I pick up ah
suck it down I got a hammer I'm gonna
smash the piss out of you [ __ ]
that's what I'm gonna do it now
am i hitting something I don't know
I'm just gonna swing blindly until
something dies wait no I see wait did I
know you're still there oh did I kill
the heads ah killed the heads okay you
go yeah there we go yeah right where the
other one go there you are
come here you go there alright you good
you gonna yeah yeah thank you
oh oh oh I take the cake my frozen oh no
I gotta do that part again bear with me
okay I'm back hopefully this will work
this time as I walk through this barrier
yes please maybe so okay it seemed to
have work
alright so we're moving forward after I
have to say that was one of the best
horror sequences I've ever encountered
in a game that was beyond amazing
perfectly well done unbelievable
I cannot applaud that sequence more that
ranks so highly and screw you guys down
that hallway I'm not going anywhere near
you that was so amazingly well done what
am i oh I can't go that way
okay why not let's go down here with all
the other peoples that are definitely
not gonna turn into mannequins hello mr.
guitar guy hey there was a guitar on the
train does that somehow relate empty
bottles of booze are you the drunk
guitar that's freaky Wow okay wait a
minute aren't you that same lady that
was on the train hey hey you hey
intercede I'm gonna intercede on this
hey ru you look dumb Brooke yeah punch
I'm stunned thousands of squats per day
I'm gonna oh I'm gonna lay down for a
bit I'm gonna give you time to escape as
I just take a nap
okay wait a minute hey I know you you're
that girl I interceded upon am I about
to intercede some more huh wait a minute
that's not a dirtier than I wanted it
sound whoops this is a family-friendly
game with demons and headless mannequins
and stuff like that oh good it says the
name of the song right there so we all
know no royalty problems here Oh for a
second I thought that was my butt so
they'll just show the main characters
but just showing it for the camera as
he's dancing the night away but that day
was her but yeah so he's on some weird
drug trip
I'm guessing or this is just memories of
him meeting his wife and I'm guessing
that this guy is the abusive husband
that would be my guess I have no idea if
that is correct but that's my guess
seems like happy memories
well that's not good huh I can't see
anything
whoa whoa I see shadows of people where
am I supposed to go okay
whoa what just happened
hahaha I'm not on the train anymore gbem
wrong I don't know offensively
inaccurate Russian okay follow the blood
trail
I guess haha cuz it's always a good idea
in horror games I love it did that
guitar player go psycho crazy bonkers
am I gonna be Slenderman down here
I gotta say this game is nailing it on
so many fronts about the atmosphere the
music the sound pretty much everything
that I've encountered in this game has
been awesome you know I got stuck a few
times without my own dumb fault
this game is but it's what the best play
is really creepy why am i down here what
am I looking for why oh there's a
doorway over here well let's go see
what's inside hopefully it's good can I
even get in here I don't know if I can
okay yes I can hey wait a minute
isn't that's the inside of my house and
doesn't make much sense or is it hang on
maybe it's not as a note here I saw that
yeah I saw that
can't hide from me we used to follow the
way which kill us that didn't make my oh
there's a next on here too ah I got a
gun that's not good that's not a good
thing or it maybe it is a good thing but
considering I already believe that I'm
if there you are again I already believe
I'm a little bit psycho so maybe I
shouldn't have a gun that's okay ma'am
got it
cuz I'm I'm just that smart
okay that's not good music I mean it's
good music but it doesn't mean good
things for me okay what what what what
tell me what who see you shoot lab daddy
ah seshu yourself did you just shot
yourself better not have or if you did
that better have been part of the story
okay good
bout to say what the hell this game man
this game man
I got a you know when I got this game
the reason there wasn't a download link
is because I downloaded it through a
torrent and I didn't want to uh send you
guys to a torrent site because they can
be pretty iffy and I don't even know the
developers website or anything like that
okay what are we doing did we just kill
this guy pawn broker seriously injured
okay so he's not dead make an anonymous
call to the ambulance
okay uh are we done all right and you
pick up the bag what bag I don't see a
bag where oh hi it's you guys ken what
are you doing oh there's the bag okay
man those why taxes aren't very obvious
all right I'm ready
come on that who who shot me I was ready
to go you gotta be joking me I was going
oh you got a really really really really
wait I already got the bag what am i
doing
wait what whoa oh that's what oh I
missed that step okay got it
let's go let's go go go let's go man we
got to get gone we got to get it up and
get it out uh stop no don't shoot him
that's bad just walk away really quickly
and he won't shoot at us and am i back
on the train now I'm Evan wait a minute
wait what now I'm in a gym
hi you guys are we're uh okay just walk
a straight line don't let him get me oh
come on how was I supposed to get away
from Emma there's not much room to walk
okay I just got it can't let him grab
for me okay just got time it did oh come
on let's below now I can't even see
these guys okay
haha how am I supposed to get past him I
have no idea
uh-huh there we go okay now just don't
grab for me man don't do it
all right made it sweet yes
checkpoint maybe or are we getting close
to the I don't know how long this game
is by the by I apologize I don't know I
haven't seen the dialog that said it
saved so I'm going to assume that it's
not a checkpoint okay is this me in my
jail cell I'm assuming that the Train is
like the Train is actually in my mind
and I'm going insane or is that guy dead
I'm so confused I'm so confused guys
I have no idea guys okay all right we're
back now
save point okay what man this game is so
incredibly well done I can't even begin
to describe him in any way I'm gonna
stop it here before something horrible
happens which that music is kind of
really really freaking ominous oh my god
so anyway oh man get excited for the
next part guys so thank you all so much
for watching click the annotations for
more videos that I've done and as always
I will see you in the next video
ah
away with that sentiment I will follow
it to struck I'm point
why do they have to be
you